[Musique]
tu veux pas grave on s'entête
je viens d'un pays
j'ai fait connaissance avec un mandat et
assyriens ça doit être quelque chose on
vous a vu sa gamine comme ça seul
tricheur
ce qui n'a je veux voir mes livres
[Musique]
je sais pas ce qu'on va devenir tous les
deux je suis tellement peur là je me
fous ce jury dick m'envoyer être son
tuteur
[Musique]
je m'étais jamais imaginé que je devrais
m'occuper de ma nièce un jour
[Musique]
et où la brosse à dents moment t'es pas
chez toi ici c'est pas toi tu dis si
pour les brosses
[Musique]
on a besoin de toi
la pression serait plus simple puis la
bombe
[Musique]
la batterie
tu pense qu'on va réussir à supporter
tous les jours tous les jours
où l'on a besoin